so hi everyone uh and good morning for
wherever you are
and um i'm shafi golosar i'm the
director of the simons institute
and uh i'm really truly delighted to
welcome our speaker today
javier
but i did it better before and
javier has held a chair of foundations
of software reliability and uh
theoretical computer science at the
technical university of munich he has
held the chair of software reliability
and security
at the university of stuttgart
and the chair of theoretical computer
science at the university of edinburgh
javier escorted a book on free choice uh
petri nets and oh come on you are going
to read all that
now i'm selecting an
unfolding approach to model checking and
is published extensively in the
fields of automatic program verification
program analysis and concurrency theory
and automated theory
so javier is as we said they published a
book but not only that contributed to
the theory of petri nets was one of the
initiator the unfolding approaches to
model checking
automatic theoretical approaches to
software model checking and verification
of infinite state machines
and
more recently his turn to working on
program fundamentals of program analysis
verification of parameterizing
stochastic systems
and javier is also highly decorated he
holds an honorary doctor informatics
from the massage university of bruno and
he's a member of the academy european
recipient of erc
and today's talk is entitled a wonderful
title back to the future as we see in
the also
cover page a fresh look at linear
temporal logic
i just want to say a word before we let
kavil take the stage and welcome him on
stage
is that uh a word about the series um
this is a series
named richard uh
m carp distinguished uh lecture series
and we established is serious in honor
of
the carp who was the simon's institute
founding director
and as we all know he's really uh the
father of a father of theoretical pure
science formulating essential problems
contributing stunning results in many
areas of computational complexity and
algorithms a true visionary
and we are very grateful to his many
contributions
a and this series is a small token of
our appreciation so please uh help me
welcome
javier and i'm looking forward to his
talk so
okay thank you very much thank you for
the introduction it's not every day that
you are introduced by a student award
winner this goes straight to my cv
and
so thank you for the invitation as well
so uh today i want to talk about a
fresh look at linear temporal logic and
this is joint work with john kratinski
and salomon secret as you can see here
and i think it's fair to say that
actually they have a larger share in
this work than i have myself
so uh now and then here in munich i have
to teach a first gr course on discrete
math and i have to introduce students to
logic and i like to tell them that logic
is what you do when you go to a bookshop
you go to the section on fantasy and
science fiction
you pick a book at random from the shelf
you open it
you read this this sentence if all of
under snatches are borrow goes and all
borrow ghosts are slightly then all
wonders notches are slightly and then
you say true
and of course the paradox is how can you
say that this sentence is true if you
don't know what you're talking about and
after a moment of reflection of course
you notice that
the meaning of this sentence depends on
the meaning of all its words but the
truth of this sentence does not depend
on the meaning of all words it only
depends on the meaning of some words in
particular this sentence is true
whatever x y and z are
so this is my favorite definition of
logic logic is the subject of
identifying true statements in a
language of which you only know a few
words
and this also gives you a very easy way
of defining what's temporal logic is the
logic where the words you know in the
language are the words of propositional
logic so you know what and and or and
not means and if then and then you also
know a few words about temporal uh
aspects of language right or about
temporal words like today tomorrow
eventually or never
temporal logic started as a branch of
mathematical logic started to be studied
by mathematical logicians at the end of
the 19th century
but i think it's fair to say that
it remained a rare flower an exquisite
flower
not known to many people until
when amir ngueli proposed it as
proposed temporal logic as a language in
which to specify properties of
concurrent and
reactive systems and in which to reason
about them and i know that orna is in
the obvious this is a very nice picture
of amir i like very much and also with
with orna there
so um
the idea what what amir observed of
course is here you have some examples of
specifications
of reactive systems and what i mean
observe is that they fit exactly this
pattern you have some technical jargon
you know nothing about like like
the wreck close estate or what the hell
is an adt
or uh well probably you can guess what
the okay button is but maybe you don't
know for sure and all this is linked
with uh
terms that come from temporal aspects of
language from temporal words right like
all the things that you see there in in
bold phase
so
this is the temporal logic that amirk
worked with almost then throughout his
career linear temporal logic which as
any temporal logic extends propositional
logic with temporal operators the syntax
we are going to use today is not the
standard one it deviates slightly from
the standard one so let's go through it
so first you have yes propositional
logic but propositional logic in
negation normal form where you can only
have negations in front of atomic
formulas atomic propositions
then you have the
standard
temporal logic operators that
probably many of you know about
this one which means
next phy one with semantics tomorrow
five one will hold
and this one five one until five two
with semantics fight two holes at some
point in the future at some day in the
future and until then
every day satisfies phi one
so uh
specifically important for this torque
is
the weak until operator which is less
known
and which is of course it's called weak
until so it's similar to until the idea
is that phi 1 weak until phi 2
holds if phi 1 until phi 2 holds
or if phi 1 holds forever so this means
it is no longer necessary to have a
point in the future at which phi 2 holds
so this is the logic we are going to use
today the syntax we are going to use
today some of you those of you who know
quite a bit about
ltl they will they might ask why don't
you have
these operators and the answer is don't
worry you can imagine that they are
there but for the for reasons of
presentation i am not going to to have
them and then
something that we also have to
spend a couple of seconds talking about
are past operators so you could also add
past operators to this logic for example
instead of tomorrow something will hold
yesterday something holds that would be
another operator or scenes instead of
until and in fact americanally used
america used these these temporal
operators in uh
in quite a few papers when you have
those temporal operators additionally
then the logic is usually called past
lto so past ltl contains both past and
future operators and future
the the standard ltl the name ltl is
reserved usually for the case in which
you only have the future operators
another important thing that i can
already tell you is that both are
equally expressive so for every formula
with past operators you have another one
which is equivalent to it without past
operators which is a very nice result
and then there are two abbreviations
which probably most of you are familiar
with because these are this is what you
see most of the time in examples in
papers and so on
this operator which is read eventually
phi or finally phi which can be
expressed
like this and which means there is a
point in the future at which five holes
and then g psi
always in the future
five holes and just remember that f
is linked to until
and g is linked to w
okay so this is just to show you how
fantastically now you can
formalize specifications in terms of
temporal logic don't worry you don't
have to understand any of this it's just
to give you a visual impression
and then
we move to the next point which is what
did amir did
after
he published his paper the first paper
on on temporal logic he embarked into a
10-year actually a bit more even
research program
where
and in the second part of that research
program he was accompanied by soharmana
and
the program was about
developing temporal logic as an
specification or reasoning language for
verifying for specifying and verifying
reactive systems and it culminated
in these two books
as you can see published in 92 95 and
there was even a third volume which was
unfortunately not finished
and uh not published and which was the
spine of this research program so the
spine of this research program was uh
what is called or what actually saw
harman and amy call the safety progress
hierarchy which is a classification of
the properties of temporal logic okay
and there are these
classes in the
in the hierarchy and they give different
characterizations of these classes in
particular a syntactic characterization
in terms of syntactic classes of
formulas right and it was
they used they introduced this
classification in past ltl so the
classes of formulas were formulas
including past operators but you know
they saw for example they showed that
every formula is equivalent to a formula
of this form uh where phi i and psi i
contain only past operators
and you know they had this hierarchy and
the idea was then to introduce proof
rules for
the different classes in this hierarchy
you don't have to understand this but
these are taken from the book and you
can see examples of proof rules here
actually with a different notation this
could be a g and this could be an f but
never mind the important thing is that
this was
what they wanted to do was to develop
proofs of concurrent programs so
actually this was a logical uh
endeavor a logical enterprise and the
goal was to produce proofs
probably also proofs that could be also
produced by humans so necessarily
automatic proofs
so uh
of course a key result then for this
for this research program is the normal
form theorem
the fact that every formula is
equivalent to a reactivity formula to a
formula in this form
okay so this is a central result in the
ideas of
of mana melee
so uh let's look at the proof of the
normal of this normal form theorem the
proof was presented in this paper but it
was not presented in the paper it was
announced in the paper in the paper you
only find this
and in fact if you look for it in the
book or in some survey papers that manam
nuelle wrote you will not find it there
it is always you find always something
like this proof is out of the scope of
this paper or of this book or of this
survey so in fact if you want to find
the proof you have to go directly
now to the phd thesis of lenore thack
chuck that you can find in the web
and let's have a look at the at this
proof so
chuck starts with a past ltl formula
and then uh translates it into a
counter-free semi-automaton whatever
that means don't worry we will not be
using that
then
in box she invokes the kronrow's
decomposition theorem to go from the
counter-free semi-automaton to a
star-free regular expression
and then
uh translates the starfire regular
expression into a past ltl formula in
normal form okay so about half the
thesis you could say is devoted to the
proof of this theorem and moreover this
last step has a non-elementary blow up
okay
so
things
probably
get a bit better
because of this paper which was
published much later as you can see and
there or that mahler probably finds
something the paper is about something
else probably you can derive a triple
exponential bound from there but in any
case it's looking pretty bad right
it's looking pretty bad and the problem
is that since then nobody has had a look
at this again
and i must say that i find even though
there is no lower bound
and i find this pretty remarkable right
so you have here a central result in the
main research program of a turin award
winner
and nobody has tried to
find
the matching bound or see whether this
there is a faster algorithm
okay so actually very very remarkable
and why is that
well
i think that
you could say that probably that the
culprits are these two guys are vardy
and walper who publish in leagues 86
this paper
presenting the automata theoretic
approach to automatic program
verification
i think there is some debate whether
they were the first to to do this or
whether uh work former work by amir on
on tableau could also be called automata
theoretical approach who cares
definitely they were the guys who
discovered it last and after after this
work the automata theoretic approach
stayed discovered okay and the stomata
theoretic approach translates the
formula for example a formula like this
into
an omega automaton
typically a bishop automaton
and then essentially you throw the
formula away
everything else is done
with automata theoretical algorithms so
this means that you don't need to
have proofs anymore proofs are replaced
by computation
so you have no need for hierarchies
proof rules action systems or anything
okay
and the automata theoretic approach was
so successful that actually it uh you
know people probably thought or even
amir himself who knows thought well
this logical approach actually is not so
exciting maybe we should do more
exciting things on the automata
theoretic side
so
in a sense and this is of course kind of
a slogan this approach demotes ltl
to kind of syntax for automata
so you write your ltl property you
transform it into an automaton and then
you can safely forget about ltl
so
and during the next decades you know uh
the automata theoretic approach was
extremely successful
so it was implemented in very
sophisticated and very successful in
industrial strength tools it was
extended to the verification of
probabilistic systems where you want to
check whether a property holds with
probability one or with probability more
than a certain threshold and it was also
applied or extended to reactive systems
synthesis so instead of worrying about
checking whether an existing program is
correct you want to the
automatically derive the program from
the specification and there has been
quite nice successes in this area in
particular there is a nice reactive
systems competition that has been going
on for for several years
okay
however
these developments come with an
associated challenge
so reactive synthesis the application to
synthesis
requires to translate ltl into
deterministic automata and infinite
words
contrary to the case of verification
where non-deterministic automata are
also fine
and probabilistic verification requires
to translate ltl not necessarily you
could also deterministic automata are
also fine they require a little bit less
you could do with limit deterministic
omega automata so uh don't worry if you
don't know what that is we will come to
that point uh later the point is as you
know that deterministic automata tend to
be larger than non-deterministic ones
right and uh
for for on the one hand sorry and on the
one hand we have the theoretical
challenge whether this is at all
possible
and this challenge was solved by safra
in
1988 who gave a determinization
procedure for omega automata and
by moshe and
kurkuweti sanjana kakis in uh 95 later
who gave a limited terminization
procedure for omega automata so the
theoretical challenge is solve but then
you have the algorithmic challenge
because as i said deterministic automata
have this bad habit of being much larger
usually than non-deterministic ones and
in fact these translations have a double
exponential blow up
contrary to the
case of non-deterministic automata where
the blow up is only single exponential
and also they are monolithic and very
combinatorial monolithic means that okay
you define the automaton in one go you
say okay the states of the deterministic
automaton are just these mathematical
objects right and for example in the
case of safra's deterministic automaton
these states are
trees of sets of states of the original
automaton
and of course there are very many trees
of sets of uh trees of sets of states
when you have a deterministic automaton
of a few even of a few states right and
the problem is that this combinatorial
explosion is actually quite hard for
implementations to deal with
so there is an algorithmic challenge
which is still going on coming from uh
and it's been going on for for probably
more than 20 years
so just to give you an example this is
for example taken from a paper in in
2016 right and you see here some
formulas which are pretty small
and here you can see how the
deterministic automata using suffrage
construction
grow
in the number uh so the number of states
of the of the automata as you can see
this looks
pretty bleak
so uh
you have all seen i hope the movie back
to the future right so you can imagine
you are now mcfly who is has got into
computer science as is asking how can i
improve these translations into automata
how can i do better in the future and
then doc comes and says
yeah we have to do better in the past we
have to go back to the past and repair
this problem with the normalization
theorem right and mcfly says why what is
the what is the the the connection and
doc answers uh no time i'll tell you
later just go
so they jump into the delorean and they
go to the 1980s back to the 1980s to the
safety progress hierarchy and to this
problem that the blow up is
non-elementary
so the first thing they do
is to observe that there is another
hierarchy of ltl formulas
and uh let's call it the alternation
hierarchy okay and it's actually very
easy to define
the it's very similar to the polynomial
time hierarchy
and
although it is it doesn't have to do
with it with complexity but the idea is
that the
the class sigma one is the class of
formulas where you only see until
operators you know remember that we had
so
next operators you can always have and
remember that on top of those we have
until and weak until so here we only
have until
and
oh this should be pi one sorry there is
a typo there pi 1
there you only have weak untils
delta 1 boolean combination of sigma 1
and pi 1
sigma 2
at most one alternation
between u and w and u and the outermost
operator is an until so you go from
until to week until by two
you go from week until two until
delta two boolean combination of both
okay
and uh well these two look uh very
similar these two hierarchies okay
and then in fact uh
chunk man amp newelli in 92 they have
already proved that in fact these two uh
hierarchies coincide or almost prove it
there is a nice paper by
pellanek and straycheck in 2005 giving
spelling it out
okay so actually instead of considering
this hierarchy you can consider this one
where notice all operators now we only
have future operators we have got rid of
the past operators
okay so now the normal form theorem
becomes every formula is equivalent to a
delta two formula
but we still have if we try to uh if we
apply the the the the the results or the
the procedure of leonard sac then we get
this non-elementary blow up
so uh
let's demystify normalization and let's
see that let's prove that
actually all this is completely
overblown there is a much simpler way of
proving this theorem
and let's do it by example
so let's consider a formula where we
have two alternations right so you have
f g f and remember that f is associated
to until g is associated to weak until
so here you have two alternations okay
so let's do the following let's look at
the
innermost alternation okay which is this
formula
and within that formula let's look at
the inner part which is
this okay the blue part
and now let's consider two cases
let's consider the case where this
innermost blue part right
holds infinitely often
so assume that i told you i give you the
additional information
i am only considering
words where
this formula holds infinitely often
and then we have case 2 where
the formula only holds finitely of
okay let's consider the first case
here we have this formula this formula
says it is always the case
for at every day from now on
either b holds
or there is a point in the future at
which c holds
so now imagine that i give you the extra
information that fc holds infinitely
often
it is infinitely often the case that
some point in the future satisfies c
in particular this means that c holds c
itself must hold infinitely often
and therefore since this is an or
this means that the formula holds
so this means under this condition
under this condition
this formula
is equivalent to true
and now let's consider the other case
where
fc only holds finitely often right
okay remember what this formula says
this formula says
it is always the case that b holds or
some point at some point in the future c
holds
okay if fc only holds finitely often
then in particular c also holds only
finitely often this means there is a
point in the future such that from that
moment on c never holds again
for example imagine c is there is a
pandemic so that would be fantastic
right there is a point in the future
such that
it will there will never be a pandemic
again
well in that case you know that if i
want so i know that if i want to make
this formula hold
from some point on
i will always have to make b hold or the
only possibility is to make b whole from
some point onwards
and this means that this formula is
equivalent to b or fc holds until i
reach that point
at which gb holds and that point must
come because i am working under this
assumption
okay good if you have got this
essentially you have almost proved the
normalization theorem because what's
happening here here we are saying this
formula under this condition is
equivalent to a formula without any
alternation
and this formula where we have an
alternation of the form w u
we have transformed or is equivalent
under this condition to a formula of the
opposite
polarity right now we have a u a stop
operator and then a g here
and now as you can imagine well right i
hope this is an aha moment for you if
you have a way of
reversing the polarity you can get rid
of alternations
okay
so let's see let's try to make this work
right so we start with the formula
and then we say okay either
gfc holds or gfc does not hold right so
this is just a logical equivalence using
only propositional logic
and now
i can see i look at this innermost
alternation right
and what do i do i replace there this by
true
and now some of you some alert should be
going in your brains and saying hey hey
hey you cannot do that
and you are partially right i cannot do
that and why not
because of the reference point of these
two formulas this formula here
refers to the origin of time
but this formula here refers to a
different point the origin of time if
you want is a different one it is the
point at which for example this a holds
okay it is referring to a different
point in time if you didn't get this
don't worry very much because the only
important thing is you cannot do this in
general you cannot
if you have this hypothesis out here
you cannot take a sub formula and
replace it by an
equivalent formula it would be fine if
you would put the hypothesis there
okay at the right point
but now comes the second aha point
namely that no this is correct
actually you can do this in this case
and why because this is not an arbitrary
formula this is a very special formula
it is infinitely often c
and if infinitely often c is true at
some point in time
it is true at any point in time
okay it doesn't matter where you put the
origin of time
it will still be true
and that's why you can really do this
you can put the
this
hypothesis out here
and you can replace here
these sub formulas by equivalent
formulas
this works
and now we are done actually because we
now have here the formula we have here
is already a formula with only one
alternation
in fact we can clean it up a little bit
uh sorry this one not yet but after we
replace
the innermost formula by this one what
we did before it is
right and if we clean it up a little bit
this is what we get and now this is
a formula with only one alternation you
can convince yourself because here you
see an until and
a g but that's the only alternation you
see and here you also see only one
alternation and so on
okay
if you want we have done the triple
somersault
let's do in a second let me show you
that this also works with a four tuple
somersault right with another four tuple
sorry a quadrupole server salt
let's do a quadrupole somewhere salt
with
fgfg
and let me just go quickly through the
steps
we look at the innermost alternation and
within the innermost alternation we look
at the innermost part
then we consider two cases in this case
now since the innermost part is gd
we consider the case that fgd holds and
the case that not fgd holds
right
and then again we are going to replace
these things
by equivalent things under this
hypothesis
in this case this is what we get
okay
you say you remember the other
before we got true and now we get here
false and we got something a bit more
complicated and now we get this right
and in fact in this way
we have already reduced we have already
found an equivalent formula with only
this part that still has to be handled
now we have we only have to do a triple
somersault here
okay
and again now we look at this
we look at the innermost alternation and
within that we look at the innermost
part
we consider now again two cases the case
where you know this is the innermost
part and we consider the case where that
holds infinitely often or not
this is what we get
and now we replace the red part
once we will replace this one
so we will be able to replace the part
above by true and below we have to
replace by this thing
and
then
if we clean it up this is finally what
we get
okay
that's it
you don't need any counter free automata
you don't need any uh
regular expressions and how much the how
which blow up do you have
well for that we can go to this closed
form expression which is a little bit
more technical than what i just showed
you and that you can find in these
papers right
this closed form expression tells you
that the formula phi is equivalent to
this thing
okay and now let's look at this thing
and try to interpret it
so here we have
a big disjunction
over all possible subsets of u sub
formulas of antilsa formulas
and all possible subsets of weak until
sub formulas of the original formula
okay
there is an exponential
number of ways of choosing these subsets
this is going to give us an exponential
number of disjuncts
and what is the role of these sets of
formulas of this m and this n
so the idea is that intuitively these
are the formulas that
that hold infinitely often
for which gf holds and these are the
formulas where f g hold so you are going
you are considering several
cases you are considering the case where
this set of formulas m holds infinitely
often and this set of formulas n holds
almost always and then a different case
corresponding to another choice of m and
n and then a different choice and a
different choice okay and this gives you
a disjunction with an exponential number
of disjuncts and now for each choice for
each way of choosing m and n
what do you do well you have this
conjunction
telling you that all the formulas inside
hold infinitely often and there is a
technical point here because this
formula is not psi it is something some
psi prime we don't have to get into that
right all the formulas
in n
hold almost always
okay
and this is the formula that
is equivalent to the original one under
the assumption
okay
and now you do the
simple a little bit of math right so
here you have a linear number of
conjuncts and each of the conjuncts has
linear length
here you have an exponential number of
these junks this formula here can have
exponential length what you get is
exponential length so not
a non-elementary blow up not a triple
exponential blow up you just get a
single exponential blow up which is not
works than bringing a sat formula
boolean formula into conjunctive normal
form
okay so now back
from the past
and if you remember the movie when we
come back from the past
the present has changed right because of
what we did in the past
so has the present change uh is our
algorithmic challenge going to be uh
solved at least in a certain way
well uh remember the first part of the
algorithmic challenge which was uh to go
from ltl to limit deterministic buffy
automata and the algorithm that was
available for that before we
moved to the past was this algorithm by
curcuvettis and janakakis
we come back from the past and we find
it now replaced by a different algorithm
okay which goes as follows i mean the
formula is first normalized
and then the formula is transformed into
a limit deterministic visual automaton
why did nobody think about something
like this think of something like this
before for the simple reason that nobody
thought this could be useful because
this step was so costly
that it doesn't matter what you do after
it
but now we see that this step is not
costly okay so we can now think about
that
okay and how does this look like so i
don't have time to give you uh uh
to get into technical details but let's
see if i can give you the gist of the
idea at least convince you that this is
a very natural way of doing things so
that you are inspired and have a look at
the paper
so first of all of course i haven't told
you what is a limit deterministic buchi
automaton
so um
first of all well i hope you will know
at least most of you what's a bishop
automaton if not it is also not that
essential
but what is a limit deterministic bc
automaton so it is an automaton which
has two components the initial component
and the accepting component
and define the accepting states they are
only in the accepting component
okay
and both components
are deterministic
so this means that the only
non-determinism
is in these transitions because you
could have for example this transition
could be labeled with an a and they jump
also with an a
right and these are jumps that bring you
from the initial component to the
accepting component
now
even if you don't know what a bishop
automaton is probably it is clear for
you that in order to accept the word you
are going to have to jump if you stay
here here there are no no no no no
accepting the states you will not accept
any word so you have to jump
but the only non-determinism that you
are going to have in a run on an
infinite word is when to jump
okay so that's the only thing that is
non-deterministic you choose the point
at which you jump
by the way this is what helps you
i told you that uh the limit
deterministic visual automata
helps you in probabilistic verification
and i can give you an idea of why that's
the case
in a normal
buchi automaton
if you take a word if you pick a word
there can be an uncountable number of
runs on that word because the word is
has infinite length and at every moment
you can branch
okay
in a limit deterministic bishop
automaton there is always only a
countable number of runs because the
only thing the run is completely
determined by the moment you jump
okay so if you say i'm going to jump
after six steps then the run is
completely determined by that
and this means now that if you imagine
that the set of runs on a word has a
certain probability which is not zero
in the normal in in the case of a normal
visual automaton since you have an
uncountable number of of runs on that
word
you may split that probability so that
each run gets probability zero there are
uncountably many that's no problem
but if you only have countably many if
you have to distribute a non-zero
probability into a countable number of
runs then at least one run has to get a
non-zero probability and that's
something that you can exploit in order
to do probabilistic verification
very well
okay in any case now that i have argued
why this could be interesting
how are we going to go from a formula
like this this is the formula with the
two alternations right two a limited
deterministic
visual automaton so first we normalize
okay
and in fact this part is going to be
easy let us concentrate yes in
giving a limited deterministic bush
automaton for that part
okay
so we have to map
essentially this thing
to something like that
and now that we know
that the meaning of jumps then there is
a very natural mapping right
this part of the automaton maintains the
formula that must hold at the moment at
which gbs starts to hold everything here
goes around when is this formula
starting going to to hold at which
moment that's the non-determinism right
where the automaton is going to
guess the right moment
to do the jump so it will guess the
point at which gps starts to hold and
then once it is here
it will check that this conjunction
holds the formula that must hold at the
point at which gbs starts to hold but
essentially that's a formula without
alternation
right and
the formula that mass hole always holds
which is also a formula without
alternations and for those it is easy to
give deterministic automata so that's
why this thing works
and here you can see a bit of size
reduction right
before
you had to use i mean the the
probabilistic verification was used was
was done with the suffra construction so
these are the numbers you had to deal
with before and these are the numbers
you have to deal with the new
construction
you have to deal with in the new
so now what about the other
part
going from ltl to deterministic automata
in this case to deterministic ravine
automata
before we went to the past this was the
algorithm
that was there
and now after we come from the past this
is the new algorithm we first normalize
then we transform the normalized formula
into something called a very weak delta
two alternating bishop automaton
and then we go from there to a
deterministic gravity in automaton
so let me give you an idea this is going
to be actually a part where which is
only for the people who are a bit know a
bit more about automata theory and ltl
right let me give you an idea of how to
go from here to there and from here to
there
well uh
it is well known
that you can transform an ltl formula
into what is called a very weak
alternating visual automaton
and this is an automaton for i am using
the
dnf normal form for this so to speak is
an automaton with uh which can have
universal
transitions okay and what that means is
that
in the case that b does not hold what
this means is that
you can go from this state you go from
this state the automaton splits into two
one copy goes here and the other copy
stays there stays in the same state and
this continues
maybe the automaton will split again and
again and again okay the run of the
automaton on the world is going to be a
tree
so
what happens after the delta 2
normalization
the important thing is that as you can
see here
you can have alternations between
accepting and non-accepting states
non-accepting accepting and accepting
accepting you can have arbitrarily many
after delta normalization you have at
most one alternation in every path of
the automaton so if you start with a
here with a non-accepting state all that
can happen is that at some point you
have an accepting state and from now on
anything
is everything is accepting
okay
so what you can do is translate your ltl
formula into a disjunction of this
automata where each path has only one
alternation
and
that allows you to prove a lemma i am
not going to get into it right
which very much simplifies the condition
that the run has to satisfy in order to
be an accepting run
and using that lemma
you can basically go from the
alternating automaton to a deterministic
buchi or kobushi automaton depending on
which formula you start with
using what is called i mean or a little
reformulation of what is called the
breakpoint construction which is
straightforward construction i am not
going to get into the details of that
but the thing that you can keep in mind
is this
instead of the states being sets sorry
trees of sets
now you move to another construction
where the states are pairs of sets
and the combinatorial explosion is much
more manageable pairs of sets are much
easier to deal with than trees offsets
and that's the key point that allows you
to do to do this
all this is by the way implemented
and you can go you can for example start
trying this these translations before i
finish this talk by going to the online
demo at this url these are this gives
you all the translations into automata
from ltl into automata and this other
tool which
equally i mean you can also start trying
out before uh this for this store
finishes
implement i mean uses all this to do
reactive synthesis uses these
translations and other
other other techniques in order to do
reactive synthesis and i just want to
give you a visual impression of what
this means
so here you have i hope you can more or
less read it here you have a set and a
specification
which is telling you which property
must be satisfied
between the relation
about the relation between inputs and
outputs to a system
so if you imagine a system where uh
inputs come and outputs are produced
inputs come our outputs are produced
right then
you have to you define a certain
relation
on how these things have to evolve in
time by ltl formulas and then by
clicking a button you obtain
this controller for this specification
which is correct by construction and
is uh in this case is going to take just
one second or something like that
and
i think that's all i wanted to say
because also it's i have to wrap up
so this talk i call the fresh look at
ltl and why that
well
imagine you would have to rewrite
the book on sat
without using the conjunctive normal
form
because nobody had thought about that
so that would be a nightmare imagine you
have to rewrite the book on first order
logic without discoloration
so i think that in a sense that's what
happened to ltl
we didn't we were not able to use the
delta to normal form or we didn't think
too much about it because we thought it
was so expensive
so i would like to just encourage you to
think about
all these things right all the things
that
that you have done with ltl in your
papers and think again oh
could i simplify what i did by
normalizing first because now
normalizing is not expensive
so and that's it thank you for your
attention
thank you very much for a wonderful talk
there's one question here
or is it conceivable that one can still
do better
we don't know the question here so we
don't know so start trying
we think of course we conjecture that
there is an exponential lower bound but
we are not sure
and in fact we have been we are one
minute
yeah
if there's more
questions i can ask a question i'm sorry
for probabilistic model checking xavier
there is also the kokobiti nakakis
exponential construction from bushy
automata to
deterministic in the limit yeah
it is based on subset constructions you
don't need to do stuff uh to do
probabilistic model check that's correct
but i couldn't show you any experimental
results compared to that one because
nobody has care to implement it as far
as i know why and also
that's a very good question but also
there is another point the construction
of corcovettis and janakakis you can
only apply it for qualitative
model checking if you want to show that
something holds with probability one it
does not work for quantitative
our construction also works for
quantitative and in fact if you replace
the raving automaton by the limit
deterministic bush automaton
you don't you then what you have to do
from that point on is exactly the same
so you don't have to you don't need to
reprogram to to you know to re-implement
prism
you just
replace the automaton by the new one and
use the same algorithm
okay so that's what made us made it
possible for us also we have also i mean
salomon seeker has experimental results
on on doing probabilistic verification
in this way reusing prism it doesn't
have you don't have to re-implement it
okay thank you
anybody else i think thomas or you just
yes yes so so uh thank you very much uh
javier first for this wonderful talk i
just wanna so your your explanation uh
showed how you can improve on the
understanding of
uh temporal logic
and uh and now you don't need really
automata anymore but my question is
whether do you gain any new insight on
some automata construction i mean
everybody doing automata would like to
do suffrage construction just with two
pairs of sets or do you have any any
things that goes in this direction
well of course no i'm not saying that
you don't know i'm not going to make the
same mistake again right i would say we
did that mistake before when we forgot
about ltl then we run into problems
because you know the automata were very
big and now what i claim is that
we had the the way to to move forward is
to look at to go back to ltl and
introduce logical techniques again look
at them again do not just ignore
the the or the demote ltl to just the
specification language right
well once you do that yes all our new
constructions we are giving new
translations of ltl to limit
deterministic bush automata and of ltl
to raven automata we are reusing we are
the part that is new if you want or a
part that is new is the normalization
that's a logical proof i don't know how
to do normalization with automata
probably of course there must be a way
but i don't know how to do it
and then there is the point of
once you have the normal form
moving to an automaton and for that of
course you reuse things that
you have learned but the idea is that we
can for example replace suffrage
construction by something that is much
simpler it is the breakpoint
construction essentially right and we
all know that the breakpoint
construction is easier than this on
surface construction
thank you very much and i think we uh we
need to wrap up but a really terrific
talk and maybe we can clap for you
virtually
thank you very much for listening and
for your patience yeah thank you very
much for you
okay
bye bye bye
you